bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur et
jouer en france elle fait cent mille
tests par semaine est ce que cela vous
semble réalisable
écoutez ça fait environ 140 mille tests
par jour aujourd'hui les plateformes
privées ont essayé de s'équiper
évidemment avec une un renfort important
de commandes nous espérons il ya
toujours des commandes qui sont en cours
nous espérons être prêt pour le 11 mai
en tout cas on est dans une capacité
nous a réalisé au moins cent mille tests
par jour donc je crois que on a ces
possibilités la question qui se pose de
façon plus précise c'est l'explosion de
nouveaux cas au tour de concentration
urbaine
si nous avions par exemple 100 cas qui
se déclare dans une ville nous aurions
avoir eu près de 2000 cas qui serait à
faire en quelques en quelques jours et
ses lacs effectivement il faut avoir des
renforts au niveau des préleveurs et il
faut avoir des renforts au niveau des
laboratoires donc les eaux des
départements vers nous pose beaucoup
moins de questions
on a une inquiétude quand même pour les
départements rouge alors à vous entendre
il ya donc jusque là assez de réactifs
et de machines pour réaliser ces tests
qui justement pour les pratiquer ces
tests est ce que les biologistes sont
les seuls à être en capacité de relever
cet objectif gouvernemental
ah non nous pouvons donner notre phase
analytique c'est à dire la phase de
traitement du prélèvement à des centres
de crs d'inserm ou des d'abord
vétérinaire donc nos collègues ont des
plateformes aussi que nous pouvons
utiliser suivant les besoins des
départements c'est bien ce qu indique le
texte
et l'article de loi alors il existe
plusieurs tests il ya le test sanguin le
test pcr
quelle est la différence entre tous ces
tests et il en est il en plus fiables
que les autres alors le test pcr c'est
la politique gouvernementale c'est
aujourd'hui le test qui a été choisi par
le gouvernement
il n'a pas validé aujourd'hui des tests
sérologiques ils sont actuellement en
cours d'évaluation par le cnr dont nous
attendons le rapport scientifique
ensuite ces tests sérologiques
montreront si l'on une efficience sur le
terrain c'est à dire si nous pouvons
contrôler que des patients rencontrés le
virus ou sont immunisés et ces questions
là qui reste aujourd'hui en attente de
ré
le test pcr pour que les choses soient
bien claires dans l'esprit de tous c'est
ce test qui est réalisé à l'aide d'une
sorte de bouton tige dans l'est c'est ça
oui tout à fait c'est exactement cela
c'est pas très agréable ça se pratique
en quelques secondes nous avons environ
10 à 15 secondes dans chaque narine et
nous essayons de récupérer des cellules
nasale infectées par le virus c'est à
partir de cela qu on recherche le
matériel génétique du virus c'est qu'on
identifie et qu'est-ce qu'on repère très
concrètement on repère les anticorps
protecteurs c'est ça qui est ciblé ça
pour les tests pcr nous repérons le
matériel génétique et pour la sérologie
où il nous faire ch ont des anticorps
qui sont dirigés contre le virus quand
on essaye d'avoir une immunité contre
une maladie qu'elle soit virale ou
bactérienne et se pose aussi évidemment
la question de l'immunité une fois ces
tests réalisés et là rien n'est moins
sûr tout à fait c'est les questions
effectivement qu'on se pose on a lu
plusieurs publications
d'ailleurs qui sont pas forcément
contradictoires mais en tout cas qui
évoque qu' on aurait la possibilité de
se ré infectés et une publication
chinoise qui évoque aussi le fait que
des anticorps restent très longtemps et
on sait toujours pas si le patient est
contagieux ou pas et d'autre part est-ce
qu'on pourrait être protégés si on est
réinfectés ça c'est une des questions
qui restent sans réponse aujourd'hui
ce qui signifie que malgré à cet
objectif assez ambitieux du gouvernement
vous biologiste infirmer tout ce qu'ils
analyseront ces tests risque aussi
d'être confrontés aux problèmes de
défauts négatif tout à fait nous avons
la possibilité évidemment de passer à
côté d'un test positif soit parce que le
malade est infecté depuis longtemps et
le virus a disparu dans son nez c'est
pour ça qu'on le retrouve dans les voies
respiratoires
mais aujourd'hui nous avons aussi la
possibilité de nouveaux tests qui vont
arriver peut-être avec des recherches
d'antigènes de virus dans la salive
on voit que le lien complément de
possibilités techniques qui s'offre à
nous pour l'instant on reste
essentiellement pour le prélèvement
nasal un tout dernier mot comment est ce
que vous expliquez qu'il ait fallu
attendre si longtemps pour pouvoir
réaliser ces tests
où était le problème jusque là haut le
problème tient à des causes multiples
absolument d'abord premièrement dans le
système privé vous le savez bien nous
attendions que ce test soit mis au
remboursement il n'était hormis
remboursement que le 8 mars
d'autre part nous avions une liste de
commandes auprès de fournisseurs assez
restreinte au départ près de six
fournisseurs qui s'est ouverte à 18 et
puis 39
donc on voit bien que dans un marché
mondial dans lequel tout le monde
voulait ces tests quand vous rédigez la
liste des fournisseurs et bien vous êtes
en concurrence avec d'autres et comme
nous avons un des prix de test dans le
privé les moins chers d'europe à 54
euros
nous étions pas compétitif pour acheter
de façon plus importante vous avez bien
vu qu'aujourd'hui les masques les blues
tout ça les prix explosent et donc nous
étions pas assez nous ne pouvons pas
mettre assez d'argent sur la table pour
acheter ces tests au prix fort merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à françois blanchecotte je
rappelle que vous êtes président
national du syndicat des biologistes